and i remember doing uh mushrooms one
time at school and
i remember thinking my shirt was a snake
because i'd worn a felt made shirt made
out of pool table felt they had a guy in
our town for a while his wife had died
and uh and so he
he was doing uh making shirts out of
felt at a pool table
you know they had a bad batch of pool
tables in this town next to us called
bogalusa louisiana someone had made
pool tables and the wood that they used
had termites in it
and beautiful tables but they were
disappearing
you know you could barely get halfway
through a game of damn nine ball and uh
one of the legs be missing off of the
thing you know and now you want
one of the pockets is uphill suddenly
so uh this fella in our town got the
felt off of the tables that green felt
and made shirts out of them beautiful
shirts
and he marketed it as christmas apparel
and um and so i got one man you know i
was lucky enough to cop one of them
there's only probably about 11 or 15 of
them
and i got one and i remember eating
mushrooms and wearing it at school when
i thought my arm was a snake
and that's one of the side effects of
eating uh
psilocybin mushrooms it'll snake your
arm out
you know what i'm saying you'll be
sitting there in class and next thing
you know
your arm is eating a white mouth and
you're like damn
okay okay we are we getting
vibey today okay today the science
lesson is
in my brain
so i'm you know geeked up and uh so i
excuse myself from the classroom and i
tried to excuse myself from
my arms but you can't do that
so i went into the bathroom and i stayed
in there for about four hours at school
in the bathroom and because i couldn't
if things were a little more manageable
in there
you know you could pee or you could do
the sink
or you could you know you got to meet
everybody if there were kids you didn't
know everybody has to bathroom
and so that was the beauty of being in
there was you got to meet people you
didn't know
but um the weird part was when you'd be
in there and they'd come back to urinate
for the second time
because on average people would urinate
probably two and a half times during the
day three times
and uh so when you saw some guys for the
second time they would that was a little
weird
because it's easy to kind of understand
why somebody's in the bathroom one time
it's harder to understand
why they're still in the bathroom hours
later when you go back in
and they're still in there just doing
toilet sink sink sink toilet
sink so but that was high school man
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one
you